ai ai ai
e funciona em haia
ae
definitivamente por mais estranho que eu
acompanhei toda a minha vida e eu
comprei aqui na índia ea loja era muito
pequeno que era muito apertada estava eu
eo vendedor do lado de fora da loja e
faleceu não vai entrar não e disso após
entrar se você comprar alguma coisa me
compre eu comprei pra ajudar
e essa e outras histórias da índia o
conteúdo meu show eu gravei com o
netflix fica esperto aí eu anunciar nas
redes sociais então junto eu quero saber
de você começa aqui embaixo qual foi a
coisa mais estranha que você já comprou
quanto mais diferente a coisa mais
divertida seja comprovada sua vida
beleza não esquece que gostei é muito
importante estar se inscreve o canal
para não perder nenhum vídeo novo é nóis
valeu a desgraça do meu deus
[Música]
o sufoco - a excelente trabalho no rio
tá um gênio como sou obrigado a
entrevista seria bom dar um tempo santa
mãe de deus em deixar o suco assim o
gosto e amarelo não vê outra obrigado
obrigado
quem sabe eu acho que as coisas mudaram
um pouco num ano sinto mais o amor das
pessoas que vieram antes não sei se
sinto alguma coisa mudou não sei o que
foi
sabe lá
ai meu deus do céu é difícil se manter
na mídia antigamente os inscritos via
mais rápida a toda hora pp chegando e lá
e visualização ea gritar e qual é assim
é doente
hoje eu sai meio da rua sinto a moleza
assim sabe não não tô sentindo amor das
pessoas acha que tá passando estou
conseguindo sustentar cara mídia ou te
falar que ela acaba com a gente precisa
fazer alguma coisa nova não sei lá um
campo cinema em curta por meu carnaval
do céu que eu faço a minha bebê que
cheguei
a briga não sei sem pressão mas o foco
está sendo desviada perdeu as pessoas
que tanto rir
aqui no youtube lá o felipe neto o nosso
chefe concorrência da minha casa que é
isso
ora meu deus do céu assim concorrência
tudo pelo meio escrito no canal que cá
não senhor que kannan no meu canal que
facilmente para o youtube também na loja
é você
eu trabalho na casa de 1 de outubro é
desconhecido
desconhecido dolores o meu deus do céu
agora também fundou o mesmo mas quando
aqui para eu vou dar a volta aqui
[Música]
desconhecidas conhecida minha bomba
respeito com o tempo eu tô aí na
história do deus do céu tá pior que eu
pensava eu tenho um show semana que vem
que não tem proposta dos caras em breve
já está aparecendo como dizia o meu deus
aí ela disse que eu precisava
um cardume de criança saia bem chegando
pra pegar esses inscritos lucas neto se
liga e vai montar
eu vou pegar suas criações e agente
rapaziada do celular não é nada ou
escrever no meu canal agora a pediu a
saída aqui todo mundo sabe que você como
escrito vaza daqui seguem firme em 4k lá
por pena alguma coisa alguém fala mal do
gol e meninas tudo bem seja se inscrever
no meu canal também faça face digita de
pobre
hoje não foi caso você não deixa de
jogar
hoje você quiser você pode chegar foi
chutar
não posso escrever meu deus eu não goste
e bochecha
eu não gosto mais de mim e ainda
pergunta se é horrível sugestão contado
no youtube só se ele se a fifa para
fazer rir é ele pra todo mundo te odeia
ninguém fazer alguma coisa útil além de
20 mil
é todo cagado agora desde criança e da
futura lei
ai eu corri atrás do campeão de vocês
viu mais um passinho só queria uma luz o
caminho a seguir mas em seu programa alô
cidadão que nunca pensou que podia filha
ah
é isso era isso
obrigada lucas na boca
[__] que pariu que vai fechar a porta
entendo nada no teu do san andrés um
recinto médico para abu e nos desenhos
daqui não entendo esse negócio de
estranho se ele tem que ser tudo cheio
de metáfora em outra língua
nada vem explicado a gente é daqueles
filmes merda só queria um caminho para o
sucesso
você está perdido e busca um novo
caminho para o sucesso cinco seguintes
passos
passo 1 vá até o templo do mestre chin
dependendo do tom
[Música]
a bp
achei tudo leva a erros já dá problema
nesta época quando estiver com fome e
época cuba para a genii acaso o game
meta foi bom né
por acaso eu faço o trajeto com muita
força aquele minutinho de lei agora vem
pra tomar uma estatura pequena aqui pra
casa pegou a ficha limpa também vai
levar gisele para quando tiver com muito
ódio olhar pra ele ficar com a mão no
meu corpo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah meu deus do céu que aí sofrendo aqui
estou com as coisas do céu [__] que
pariu a fazer mínima de mais cara é
sempre uma honra servir o senhor e pode
ficar tranquilo que tomou conta de jovem
também cheira mostrar muito bem os seus
cremes estão nessa mala a botar meu
crime também na frente o território não
era uma fria
eu fico um pouco nada de errado na minha
vida fui vocês também trabalha com essa
leva de maio precisa disso
agora é toda hora que estão em cima
fazendo a própria mim essa que eu faço o
que tenho que fazer é melhor deixar
sofrer um pouquinho até objetiva por
isso com 52 procurando placa plano b
quando não tem fio bica no twitter minha
casa
nada de errado pra mim tem hora que você
fica trecho e tudo certo consegui ver só
você ninja alfredo que pariu
paulo
onde casa ninguém
o opera longe do gol
o i
o
o tchan
que roupa e escroto é só de quem vende e
niju não um pouco de ninja é que o mundo
é que houve no livro o hobbit cap de
coisa rápida que a paga sem carro ficou
legal roupa eu pensei que o rio negro do
rio criticou a falta que não fazer o que
ele tem a vida
eu vim aqui cada do livro da placa de
ruby placa derrube entende eu estava
lendo um livro lá em casa e aí falou pra
eu vim procurar o mestre xin xin jorge
nem pessoa que encontrar com o mestre 58
voltas a roupa de ninja e nadja não aqui
mas vou ter tudo aqui o negócio aqui a a
roupa que a espada peixeira mortal em
oitavo com o pé na hora nessa no sangue
quente aguardando ilegal imprensa legal
também já me perguntar coisa e vocês
barrou um cara eu esbarrei foi esbarrei
israel um cara lá na pracinha entende é
que é supernormal civil todo mundo tenta
bom humor era especial é normal sair né
que você especial nossa especial para
tentar você é especial pra cá não só o
que está atrás de mim eu encontrei o
livro ela estava falando pra guardar
placa de rubi e tal aí eu fiquei um novo
objetivo é dessa placa entendeu que essa
placa lá pra casa botar na minha cama
pega essa chávez ataca de clubes uma
pessoa tem no mundo essa placa sério
para conseguir de verdade não são de
esquerda luta e aí você vê de ninja
ela faz se movimentam da madeira tudo
cai de maior da república
qual é o nome amor windows o windows
mentira mas o anderson fã sério e que é
diferente é óbvio que o filho do vento
é mentira dos anos ou sério eu sempre
que vejo o nome de fruta se eu falo que
algum significado maneira deixa eu te
falar uma coisa então vai lá então vou
liberar poder lá que o que libera as
coisas aqui tá bom tá na roça vai a
seguir você vai virar à esquerda vai dar
de cara com os eucaliptos enorme assim
se vai notar que o calypso falou de seu
pai vai dedicar também os cogumelos ali
no chão como não cair nessa tentação de
comer cogumelos que dá o negócio na
cabeça que já comunicou que fez ofertas
em fina estampa vai ver algum momento
isso é uma maluquice mas vale a pena
quando fazia rock vai encontrar uma oca
é essa não não se precipita vai contra
rapazes lá no méxico ele não quem está
se concentrando vai mais um pouquinho à
frente da telinha cuidado que ele
costuma ser de barros correto com essas
apa xix e sapatilha de azamor o
brasileiro brasileiro usar sapatilhas
muito filme você quer ser divertido
engraçado seguiu na reta vai ter o
mestre chiquinho muito a fim de você
você não vai utilizar mas ele vai ver
que você tá então ele vai aparecer ficar
tranqüilo quanto a isso tá bom evitar
barulho nessa hora tá tá bem então o
negócio é ir lá já aqui já não tem mais
brigado ea nós não sabe que não precisa
não ficar fazendo isso não sei até hoje
encanta mas eu não perco apertavam já
funciona já não é mais obrigado
vai lá vai lá vai lá vai lá vai lá vai
lá que eu vou comer uma fruta que eu
tomei café e bailado robson rocha que
vai encontrar coisa no caminho político
todo dia aparece um domingo
o tom
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sg social mexe
não vim aqui pra você me treinar o qual
foi o treinamento méxico
esses gostar minha placa hsx eu ganhei
só poprock merchant passei pro o carlito
você vai treinar
eu vim aqui pra isso você está engraçado
né
é só você ver um chinês de barba e aí
você acha que tem que treinar
você vai me treinar assim com essa roupa
não tem talento nem pra moda a moda eu
quero treinar apesar desse jeito aí tá
aposentado né só comendo não fazer nada
fica só em futuro não baixa caloria não
fará caminhada aí não querem treinar
como é que o seu desafio você encostar
um dedo deste rostinho bonito aqui eu te
ensinou alguma coisa
sou grande mas o leve a mal né
[Música]
a analogia é sabatinado no céu
sei que nada somente pedir pai tenha
placa
ela está super bem guardada uma base
secreta base secreta eu vou buscar minha
placa de ruby foi eu vou pegar minha
placa de rubin kazan a a
i am
ai ai ó filho felipe lucas neto onde a
tapa
eu já sei que agora vai ter de me
treinar tá ok vou te ensina mas nunca
pra mim e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aí para beijo está pronto já achei
acabou ontem nem 20 minutos que está
aqui na o curso errado cara também
online indica pelo menos a direção da
opel e assim sabe jogar de titular logo
depois como ela não não precisa explicar
nada já violentou digo isso desde que eu
voltei a treinar seus valeu não precisa
me falar que precisa assim já falou
valeu
[Música]
o
pega na bola eu me pegar
[Música]
a boy
eu quero minha placa de holguín
[Música]
aí ele finalmente depois de toda essa
[__] eu te encontrei
eu vim buscar minha placa papai você
quer isso a não vai conseguir
ai eu sou olê olá
só eu posso ter a placa derrube em seu
canal é tão pequeno que eu cheguei a
pensar que fosse paulo do pessoal que
essa placas e só duas pedras bairro não
eu também quero a placa de rubim eo
pouco que está
sequeira placa tinha medo que vamos
brincar enfim buscar melhorar não se
conquista essa placa fazer o filho de
rico e pobre
[Música]
paulo
ora ora ora se não é a chuva e do fiel e
esse babado não te pertence viável é
hora de tiro na park
ae
cuidado ela é perigosa ah tá
[Música]
em poder dele
o nome dela é que ela não é minha não
responderia sim
ai ai ai vamos de mal na bola
ai ai ai jesus
em seu portal na web mas também da força
achei a moça desculpa eu nunca vou
pensar na minha vida minha família toda
está acontecendo agora o botafogo
[Música]
ela me pegou de surpresa mas não vou
dançar com o velho
a águia branca primeiro o ai ai
o fazer respiração boca a boca no meu
paulo
desculpa eu já melhorei o espanhol
voltou melhor e melhor ator e melhor
[Música]
hum
o carro
[Música]
hum
o grupo e você pensa que acabou
[Música]
os ora se não é o chefe de todos os
filmes que a marca natal heróis lojas
uísque idéia original e
[Música]
a rã macho
ah
é o bombo e berlim
a rã
an não
[Aplausos]
ae
os outros ainda têm isso
é tempo de brincar
o hype
hum
o futuro
[Música]
ai ai ai ai meu peitinho salvador
ayew de bocha das técnicas
o
hum
que [__] é essa
eitá desgraça tomar sol era um sonho meu
explodir um carro num filme a explosão
foi boa
mantendo o contexto não teve muita venda
no lincoln acha que não consegue amarrar
com a cena teve outro momento vou
colocar explosão eu tentei escrever lá
mas não ficou legal eu resolvi montar
aqui porque a outra final e talvez foi o
que deixou eu paguei então sim mas
funcionou até que funcionou ainda fosse
um carro novo
o monstro até tentei patrocínio oscar a
máscara não quer patrocinar o café
patrocinar e capinha de iphone
carregador de celular pra sair do
negócio nada a ver queria um carro com
quem interessa agora é de que ele estava
mesmo a parte que eu só vou bater
e você só vai apanhar time tomou a aaa
olha o lucas neto
não vai sobrar e ai sabe o que você fez
agora aquele grande momento que o
mocinho tão golpe que nem sai ou mas tem
que cair na europa tem que cair na
europa
[Aplausos]
ó
ah
[Música]
você viu isso papai eu mereço a minha
placa você viu que eu sou capaz até o
domínio das técnicas marciais
eu assisto você lê e adorei também
divulgou todo mas você precisa de 50
milhões as crianças para ter a placa
tudo isso foi de medo para perceber um
get to atua o pai eo pai bateu
o povo brasileiro eu te peço agora que
você se inscreva no meu canal pra gente
chegar a 50 milhões e consegui a placa
derrube do youtube como fazer a maior
arrecadação de inscritos já feita na
história da internet
copie o link desse vídeo mande para os
seus amigos
mande por seus familiares mande lote zap
mandino face morte no twitter onde no
facebook
mande para todos onde para todos os
mundos que ainda não conhece o meu canal
festa para a pessoa se inscrever
eu quero que você se inscreva e eu
também quero que você clique em gostei
porque eu trabalho pra fazer isso aqui
eu apanhei tanto que minha canela tá
parecendo um camelo de tanto calor longo
que tem aqui nessa canela não é que eu
escute um
então clique gostei eo principal se
inscreva eu quero que todo mundo se
inscreva
vamos chegar a 50 milhões e conseguir a
placa derrube do youtube manda pra todo
mundo que os seus amigos qualquer país
que fala a língua portuguesa angola cabo
verde moçambique portugal brasil
qualquer lugar
mande pra todo mundo eu quero que a
gente recorde de inscritos
inscreva neste canal e comenta aqui
embaixo que você achou e se tiver muito
jóia nesse tipo de repente a gente faz é
o filme já pense num negócio desses
eu já tenho que ser rápido como aqui da
câmera não está agüentando mais até
balançando o rapaz do bo não aguenta
mais segurar o rapaz da lâmpada partir
desse prêmio então clique em gostei e se
inscreva
[Música]
é isso aí espero que você tenha gostado
deste vídeo a gente se empenhou muito
graves em cinco dias aqui nosso diretor
e os técnicos muito obrigado a cancelar
miguel também obrigado galera do cob
poupa ninguém aqui também ó rapaz aqui
tem da coreografia pra gente acha legal
passar todo mundo aqui que sempre olhou
pra [__] ajudou a gente obrigado a
isso todo mundo é nóis
a câmera fica oca câmera também já está
em céu e valeu galera valeu valor para a
boca
[Aplausos]